what's up GQ this is smoked purp and
these are my essentials are Sesenta lui
bag keyboard not specifically Louie just
like a black tee really the other
essentials like a black tee lotion
cologne glasses i were really wear the
glasses all the time for like when I'm
hot I just put the glasses on keep pair
glasses with me
these are uh oakley's better mix collabs
and I'm saying with the little spikes on
them I don't always wear glasses but you
know when I'm high [ __ ] there I just
smoke some gas and I know I look high
and I'm somewhere like I don't want to
look high and I'm sad I gotta throw a
month I feel like people probably still
in our lives right even with the glasses
or something like that it's worth and
these are the only glasses I haven't
lost I usually lose like all the
sunglasses I get another thing I keep
you know saying is some tea I'm not
always drinking tea but I do a lot of
shows and I record a lot so I'm saying I
gotta take care of my voice so I'll be
drinking tea I like green tea and I like
like a lil tea oh honey and lemon but if
I don't have it ah still attractive I
didn't really used to drink tea like
that it was more like what I started
going to studios and like they have it
there and they offer and stuff I just
started tranq him and it makes clears my
voice up like if there's any trouble I
grasp any sister like that
I'll do the copy on the rustics a-team
what we have here aren't pair of classic
all-white air forces these are
everybody's essential I feel like if you
wear air forces you know that you always
gotta buy a new pair you can only wear
them like once or twice and then you
gotta get a new pair so usually when I
fly on the cities and I need a pair Air
Force is some [ __ ] it's bad new pair I'm
saying cuz I performing them and like
you should wear them they get dirty and
[ __ ] like that so man it's not it's not
it's not every all white shoes cuz I
don't know I don't like every all white
shoes there's air forces right it's the
way they just like they just go with
everything you know what I'm saying like
the way jeans sit on them like if you
want to wear shorts and air forces it
still looks good I feel like the whole
point of them is for them to be crispy
and white you know I'm saying they got
to be crispy and white so yeah I run
three shoes
some of them are at my house like I just
put them in my bag and I sum these gonna
come back home with me I don't way I'm
ever again
[Music]
actually okay I couldn't do that boom
bow right there Belmont and they're
ready to go one two times get a new pair
this is some wild right here I think I
just I think I just win about it guy you
saw what Creed I felt like you got you
got to switch it up sometimes you know
and then I start and then I start again
the why so sometimes I get to D or I'm
not gonna loud you do that I do I do
something like different cologne speak
when I wanted like you know give to
something new how do you know I put I
spread my I spent like my wrist first
and then I spare like night chess and
then I actually kind of like spraying
air and then I just like spinning it why
so there you go that's the calling I
have I'm saying if anybody's over 1 to M
what smells like that so I sell a bad
coconut water I love my goal lot I found
out about this myself and I'm saying I
just seen it at a gas station oh my
let me try this I tried it it was fired
I don't know I just like this one oh
yeah
sometimes I try sometimes I drink other
ones and [ __ ] but this one is the one
that stuck I'm saying this is knowing
that I focus I always keep with me I
don't like the other coconut waters too
much it's really just this one that's
why this is in censor coconut water well
babe I coconut water essential gotta
keep one of these I love these shoes
[Music]
all right so listen I eat fruits man I
do I do keep some fruits of me something
out all the time but you know I like to
keep food to me I don't know who the
[ __ ] brought me the whole fruit I was
talking about chopped up fruits you know
I'm saying I don't walk around with a
banana and an orange I don't know what's
like I like to mix the has like the
watermelon honeydew grapes pineapple and
strawberries that's usually what's in it
yeah I don't keep whole bananas and
whole oranges everybody knows you got to
keep a black tea in a white seat I like
specifically keeping a black tea and a
white see from hmm
those are the only black teas and white
eat my like one I don't know I just like
how they fit better I'm saying only ten
bucks keep one of each one if I was
gonna I was gonna keep keeping new one
I'm not always wearing a black tea or a
white tea you know I gotta keep it just
in case I wanted to change things I want
to put on a black shirt a whitey I'm not
gonna lie a lot of times I got wear some
[ __ ] and then I'm like [ __ ] I sure
didn't want a white seat
why should I just want a black tea you
say it's like when you go out like an
attack it and then your life's like I
said it just work that's not that's off
to the buff black - you know why - you
okay so I always keep jewelry on me
also it's a reason is not an essential
because I take it off obviously I don't
I don't worry it everywhere but the
watch I feel like even when I'm not
wearing a chain I always wear I was like
wearing a watch I still wear the watch
you know I'm growing a fact there should
be a lots on my wrists all the time yeah
this was I think 70 thousand seven
something like that I'm like three hours
behind okay
that's our team that's our two coming
out December 13th don't get that [ __ ]
you go get that [ __ ] fire 213 I got
crazy fusion I got pump on edge dies on
there it should be read on its high
dollar sign Matt people on that [ __ ]
so go get that she
[Music]